who for anyone who wants to get into the
filmmaking business right now
what are some of the essential pieces of
equipment they need to have in terms of
the camera computer and editing system
what would you advise that people
purchase I think that's the great thing
about getting into filmmaking right now
is that you need so little you know
really you can't do it yourself you know
with a DSLR with a laptop with you know
it used to be Final Cut I would say
premier or I guess if you're learning
now when you Final Cut 10 is great
actually but that you know I think
people filmmakers these days don't know
how good they have it and of course the
generation before me was probably saying
that about me but essentially it's so
it's so much easier now to get a
passively good-looking image you know
with the shallow depth-of-field you have
a large sensor camera that it looks like
a movie and you go shoot something for
very little now and that wasn't the case
until a few years ago with the explosion
of DSLRs so it's a great time to be
making movies with very little money as
far as getting your foot in the door and
you know making something that resembles
a movie when I was in school we were
shooting on VHS cameras so no matter how
good your writing no matter how good
you're directing at the end of the day
it was going to be terrible so it's nice
to be able to go make something with the
tools that are out there for very little
now that you actually have it you know
look and sound good
any advice on staying ahead of the curve
it seems like so many things are
wonderful there's so many wonderful
products and they do look like film but
then they're obsolete in two to three
four or five years is that just the
nature of the beast or there are certain
things that you can purchase that will
kind of keep you ahead of the curve that
won't be as obsolete in the next few
years I just think it's a filmmaker you
can't get caught up and worrying about
being on the latest version of whatever
is out there you know we cover those
things onto a film school when it's
great to check in and know what you know
what's what the latest greatest tool is
but ultimately storytelling this time
and you know it's a very rare situation
that your camera or your equipment is
gonna be the thing that makes or breaks
your film someone said once that like
part of being a filmmaker is what do
they say gear addiction mm-hmm that you
get this sort of gear acquisition
addiction and and it's just part of you
just know that your bank accounts going
to take a hit and it's just part of the
thing is that is that something that you
have to accept being in this business or
having this hobby you know gear
addiction is something it's something
that I've suffered myself I'm a I'm a
gear addict hello my name is Ryan but
you know it's one of those things where
I think it also demonstrates your
commitment to your craft and for me ever
since I was in high school there could
have been a situation where I buy a nice
fill-in-the-blank you know are you gonna
go buy a car are you gonna go do this
and for me I was always spending money
on gear because I believed in myself and
I believe from the stories I wanted to
tell and the nice thing of course is
that the gear you buy now it may be
obsolete but you can still sell it and
so as you're sort of building up these
tools that you have in your wheelhouse
I think that you know you can view the
addiction is a bad thing but it's not
bad to invest in yourself and that's
essentially what I think buying these
tools represents in terms of research as
to which brand or whatever someone needs
to do for the various products they want
to buy how much do you spend I know
things are different because you're
running a website dedicated to looking
that up but how much time would you say
the average person should dedicate to
looking up the different reviews and
things like that on different products
we say how much time or how much money
that you spend on these things or a
little bit of both but yeah how much did
sort of due diligence should you do in
researching what brand versus Canon
Nikon whatever the way I view it is I
spend most of my time working on at this
point screenwriting
you know a few months ago it was
directing or editing depending on what
stage I'm at with various projects but
when I'm surfing the web or if I were
somebody reading no film school if I
weren't writing and managing the film
school if I was reading these things I
see that time as something that you're
doing instead of watching football on
Sunday to me it's not an exclusive and
mutually exclusive thing it's like I'm
on this website and I'm reading about
these things because I care about it and
quite frankly I think a lot of people do
these things while they're at a day job
they don't want to be at so you know I'm
reading and researching materials not
instead of working on a screenplay but
in addition to it and I think on the
money side of the equation there are a
lot of ways that you can invest in
equipment that don't require you to have
a lot of money yourself you know one is
are their loans is their financing you
can get I know that when I bought a red
camera I went and applied for a credit
card that had 0% interest for 21 months
so I paid it off it was like $300 a
month for the next two years essentially
but I didn't have the money in my
account at the time when I went to buy
it and then I sub rented it through a
rental house so that it was generating
income on xone so you know I think some
people saw an article on Brook that said
I was buying a red and they assumed that
you know I had a lot of money in my bank
account and why was I as an indie
filmmaker spending money on a camera
instead of the film itself when actually
that camera basically ended up costing
me nothing because I put it on the car
and I paid it off their submarines so I
think you have to be savvy as a
businessman when you're investing this
equipment and then if you're not
supplementing it like I have think about
what kind of income is generating for
you whether you run a production company
or whether you're a DP can add to your
day rate and just making those
calculations it's something that can you
know it should be paying you not
vice-versa
wow that's a great point yeah so so
using credit cards but using it in a
smart way where you know you could avoid
the the finance charge and in terms of
how much research did you do before you
decided on that was the camera that you
wanted and again it's different because
you know
you're the head of no film school so I
get that but in terms of like someone
else that maybe isn't doing that that
doesn't run a website how much do you
think they should devote to researching
you know I think it's not as I said it's
not gonna make or break your projects I
think there's not there's no such thing
as the best camera there's only the best
tool for the jobs that you do and
depending on whether you shoot
documentaries whether you shoot weddings
and whether you shoot features you know
all of those things are gonna be
different but ultimately we're great
it's great to be a filmmaker now because
the tools are so good and they work in
you know various lighting conditions
they can shoot different frame rates
they have audio inputs you know the
DSLRs are being hacked to do raw video
it's you know it's amazing time to be a
filmmaker and I'm gonna worry about well
I have this camera he has that camera
there for his movies gonna look better
or worse it's not really gonna be make a
breakpoint I think can you tell us the
camera that you purchased what was it
again
I wasn't read Scarlett okay and what
were the major factors in you purchasing
that camera and why didn't you rent it
versus just outright buying it
mm-hmm um I think it's a really tough
question for people to I think you know
when you make those decisions you don't
necessarily know at the time whether
it's the right or the wrong decision you
just sort of have to go off of a sense
and in a projection of what you're gonna
be working on the reason that I like the
red was I felt it did a lot of things in
the camera that other cameras needed you
needed to attach a lot of doodads to you
know whether if you wanted to get 4k on
another camera you have to attach an
external recorder normally if you want
to record the compressed raw that's not
even an option for most of these other
cameras even though red has been doing
it now for five years so I felt like it
was something that once they were
getting supported by editing systems so
you can just drag in our 3d files to the
timeline and cut natively it was
something that gave you a lot of
flexibility for high-end projects
something that you could go shoot a
feature on but also something that you
use you know as a compact package to go
film an interview you know so so the
versatility of the tool was what made me
think I'm comfortable investing in this
because it it goes in different
directions whereas I think some of the
other cameras are more specialized and
their limitations hold you back from
certain productions but you know the
camera market is changing I don't know
that I'll be shooting on a read forever
you don't know what's coming out around
the corner you know but thankfully most
of these professional tools hold their
value decently so when you're selling or
you know read has an upgrade program so
just this the the idea that it's gonna
last you for a number of years is the
the calculation for me is thinking about
how much use can I get out of this and
for how long and was that also what
factored into you purchasing it rather
than renting it's kind of like leasing a
car versus buying it did you know that
there'll be additional things I'll want
to shoot with it this is not the last
time I'm going to use this or I think as
indie filmmakers we have this romantic
idea that if you own the equipment
you're not going to be held back from
having an idea and going and shooting or
something for no money with your friends
and getting it in the can because you
already spent the money on the camera so
it's not costing you anything to go make
this movie right and there's nothing
wrong with that idea and I certainly
share that myself and and you know I
think that's that's kind of like the the
calculation behind buying something
because typically if you're only gonna
rent you know for me I'm not doing
freelance work I'm working on my own
projects and so it takes me a lot of
time to write and go through
pre-production and do that I'm not gonna
be using the camera that many days out
of the year
but I do like the idea that oh I we can
go make this thing with it with the
equipment we have as opposed to like
setting up a budget and getting
production insurance and getting rentals
and having to build that whole thing
every
negotiate something coup in your opinion
what are some of the best documentaries
on the craft of filmmaking that's a good
question I you know we talk about a lot
of documentaries and books on film
school that's kind of part of the
philosophy behind the site is that it
you know if you don't have money to go
to film school or if you're not some
place where they have a film school
nearby that you can get to that you can
learn a lot of this stuff through
documentaries through books through
websites like mine and like yours to me
my favorite learning tool for filmmaking
as far as things that are accessible to
anybody anywhere has just been listening
to directors commentaries on DVDs I
think you really get into the shoes of
the person making the creative decisions
and you can I think you can learn a lot
that way so that's been sort of my
documentary about filmmaking that I've
sort of perpetually been watching it's
just listening to the directors that I
admire talk about you know why they made
this decision or the challenges of the
shoot or you know working with that
actor and the kind of onset you know
we're not even just on set and and from
from pre-production all the way through
delivery you know they talk about these
things and then in the documentaries I
mean in the commentaries so that's kind
of the documentary to me than I thought
I'd liked a lot who we want to talk
about know film school comm in terms of
how many page views does it get each
month
what were the page view starting out and
how did you get this tremendous growth
that we've seen oh sure sure you know I
actually had lunch to a film school as a
personal blog in 2005 and that's what
that's what actually got me a job in New
York City and I moved up there and but
really the website that we think of it
as today I launched in January of 2010
and at that point just because it was a
personal blog it was averaging I think
you know 39 views a month or something
no one was reading it so so for all
intents and purposes it started at 0 and
so now we're doing 2 million page
a month we've been growing fairly
consistently since I launched it and
it's been great I mean when I launched
the site I had no idea whether anyone
was gonna read it you know I only spent
a week designing it because I didn't
want to you know sort of front load all
of work and then find out that you know
I built it but no one came so it's been
great to sort of have the community
there and we're currently completely
redesigning and we'll be relaunching it
soon I hope
but yeah so we're doing two million a
month and what was the other question
when you when you started out I just
want to go back to to starting out that
personal blog back in 2005 what was your
desire behind I think that's great that
you had a passion for it and you you
went for it probably never thinking that
it would ever turn into this so you just
wanted something like in your spare time
to kind of are you passionate about
cameras filming from 2003 or 2005 I was
a video producer in North Carolina which
is where I'm from and I just I went shot
a documentary in the Amazon jungle in
Ecuador and I could only shoot it during
my vacation that I had accrued so I went
for two weeks and that was really the
breaking point of realizing I can't be a
filmmaker and have a full-time day job
at the same time and I knew that I
didn't want to go to film school
thus purchasing the URL and so me
launching the personal blog was a way of
putting myself out there knowing that I
was recently unemployed of my own
volition
and that I was gonna be trying to get
myself to New York City but I didn't
know anyone in New York so how you know
how can I reach across geographic
boundaries well the Internet that's the
great thing about you know the world
wide web so really it was just me
talking about movies a lot and I ended
up interviewing with a couple
a film company in New York who didn't
hire me and sort of fell off the face of
the earth but somebody else read what I
was writing about these experiences and
I saw that his signature said senior
producer at MTV so you know that contact
initially was because of my website and
that's really when I you know learned
sort of about the power of the Internet
and that's really what motivated me to
to keep doing what I've been doing and
unfortunately they were hiring graphic
designers at the time and I wasn't the
graphic designer but I didn't stop me
from saying that I was a graphic
designer so you know I was able to lie
my way into a job in New York based on
creating a fake portfolio and putting on
a suit and driving myself there and
taking this interview and then doing
Photoshop training on the train every
day to and from work but that was kind
of you know the impetus behind the power
of the internet and sort of knowing how
it hit home personally was being able to
get myself from an unemployed kid living
in North Carolina with my parents to you
know working as a senior designer at MTV
in the middle of Times Square
because of my website when you first
launched that blog how many hours a day
were you putting into it I'm sure now
it's it's probably every waking minute
but in terms of back then what were you
putting into me well when I first
launched it in 2010 as the current site
it was it was a full-time job
essentially not not a full-time job
posting content but I wasn't somebody
who knew how to run a website I didn't
know things about search engines and you
know inbound traffic and marketing and
advertisements and monetization and all
the sort of things that you would see on
a website if you went to a website and
there was a masthead and it was editor
managing editor biz dev you know
outreach publicity all of those things I
had to learn about and so when I
launched the site I told myself I'm
gonna post one thing a day that way
people will know that there's something
new here every day so they can come back
and it's not gonna be something where I
post one thing
nothing for three months but during that
first year of growing the website from
nothing it was just research you know
most of my time was spent learning about
these things and and they're great
things to know about now
but I essentially had to put my film
career on hold for a year while I
learned about all these other aspects of
running a website and then once I've
been running it for a year and we
reached a certain traffic level that's
when I was able to sort of cut down in
the research just run the website and
work on my screenplay at the same time
what do you think has been the most
important thing in getting that traffic
or is probably a combination of many
things can you share some tips for other
people that want to start their own site
whatever it is if it's about food trucks
or whatever it is sewing I think you
know with websites people there are so
many websites out there that the
challenge of launching website is if
someone comes and they read something at
your site or they watch it video at your
site and they never come back because
there's just so many out there so the
challenge is how do you keep people
coming back to your site and of course
there are the usual approaches of just
having better content you know and
trying to do a better job and making
sure that your content is better written
than other people's but to me the thing
that we ended up being successful with
was when I wrote this dslrs to the
photography guy which was or still is
because we're a little out of date now
we need to update it and we're gonna do
that when we you know have some time
yeah but so that's you know one hundred
and something pages and we gave it away
for free in exchange for an email
address and anyone can sign up for it
and then unsubscribe if they don't want
to get our updates but that was the
thing that really I think kept us on
people's minds and so you came and you
got this guide and then you started
getting emails and coming back to our
site so that way we were able to grow
our community from you know week to week
and month to month as opposed to just
sort of having this revolving door of
people coming and then forgetting about
the site if someone does want to start
their own site from scratch and just
kind of dip their toe in the water what
are some what's what's sort of the quick
and dirty
some of the tips you know get the domain
name would you advise WordPress a Wix
site like what what are some ones just
to quick quick things you can advise us
someone that's a good question
you know I think it for example will
WordPress is great I've built a lot of
sites on it you know it can't beat the
price it's free and you can customize it
every which way
but I think every it's like cameras
every you know film project it requires
a different or a different camera would
be best for different you know kinds of
film projects and websites are the same
we're actually gonna be migrating off of
WordPress for our next version not
because WordPress is bad but just you
know what you're trying to do has a
different tools to something like Wix or
you know the hands does a lot of
portfolio sites which is in there now
part of Adobe's Creative Cloud if you're
using their software you know how this
portfolio website software included you
know Vimeo Pro is also something where
you can sort of host your own business
and you know host your video and all
those sorts of things so I think it
depends on whether you're primarily
trafficking in video or whether you're a
news site whether you're a community a
lot of people use like vbulletin for
forums it's just in terms of knowing
what you're doing right now and where
you want to take it and then thinking
about which tools we're gonna get you
there I think how important is it to
respond to comments in terms of building
your website whether it's just in the
thread underneath each article or also
via social media yeah you know I think
about it more from the perspective of
community engagement and right now on
the film school it's comments on blog
posts going forward it's gonna be much
more of a community where people can
talk to each other and post their own
things and and you know I think for a
blog it's very important because you are
not just it's not you know we like to
think about it I know film school as
it's not a lecture it's not a professor
up in front of a blackboard talking to
all the students it's you know a class
where the
a circle and were one of the maybe we're
a moderator or something but everyone is
basically talking to each other so I
think it's very important just how you
think about the community whether that
be comments or whether that be social
media and I think you know we've done
and we do a good job of responding to
comments I think but as far as the the
social media aspects and other things
that we could be doing we just haven't
been able to do what I would like to do
because it's a it's you know right now
it's essentially just a blog that's
gonna be changing and I think the most
valuable thing you can have as a website
is a community that you know is
passionate and comes back regularly and
you know finds value in the site that
they're participating in whether that be
in comments or some other sort of
interaction do you remember going back
to when you got your first comment your
first interaction from someone reading
and and how was that and how diligent
were you in responding yeah I think it's
one of the hardest things about starting
a website from scratch is feeling like
you're you know putting stuff out there
and no one's reading it and of course
I'm sure you guys have seen as well that
you could have a thousand people read an
article and not have a single comment or
many more than a thousand so it's very
discouraging at the beginning and I
don't remember what the first comment
was but I do remember years later
feeling like well no one can really say
anything to me now that is gonna
surprise me because by the time I
brought on other writers to the site I
had written a thousand posts and there
are twenty thousand comments on the site
so I felt like it's you know getting
comments is a very good skin thickening
procedure where you have to believe in
yourself and you have to sort of stick
to your guns and at the same time it's
great to listen and you hear a lot of
different perspectives on your work and
what you're doing but I actually should
go back and look at what the first
comment was cuz I know for a fact that
he'd go back to the very first post on
my site from 2005 where I say hey I'm an
unemployed kid in North Carolina
I'm Michael in film school but I don't
know where this film career is going
let's find out to this day there are
still zero comments on that post so I
have to go back and look and see which
which one actually somebody said
something I'm sure it's just a friend of
mine saying you know hey Roger you suck
or something but you know I'll go friend
I wouldn't put it on the wall do you
remember when you finally launched no
film school on Twitter or Facebook was
that simultaneous with oh we were late
yeah I was late to Twitter you know I we
haven't been great about our social
media presence and we need to improve at
that a lot but it's just one of those
things where there are only so many
hours in the day and we've really
focused on creating content sharing
content and you know hopefully will
become more of a social media presence
going forward well obviously two million
hits a month you're doing something
right so maybe the thing you're doing
right is staying off social I mean I see
so many people on social media and I've
had to pull back myself that it's just
it's like is this really I mean I hate
to say this but sometimes it's like a
giant circle jerk
mm-hm I'm just gonna say it and and
sorry if I offend anyone but that's what
it is sometimes I think that maybe
you're on the right path if you're
focusing more on content and responding
to things on the website rather than
just like Tooting your own horn on mhmmm
I think there are a couple of challenges
with social media on the Twitter side
it's very ephemeral you know things
drift off people's front pages in a
matter of seconds and on Facebook I
think the challenge is that you don't
really own your audience or your data
and progressively more and more Facebook
wants to charge you to be able to reach
the audience that has already given you
permission to reach them you know they
like you and then you're like well now
you like me you have to pay money for me
to say hey here's this thing so you know
for me the thing that I really focused
on instead of social media was email
because I
that I would own that and that you know
email is stickier than a Twitter post
you send somebody an email it stays in
their inbox they have to delete it or
unsubscribe or read it and so that was
really my focus because I felt like it
wasn't trendy it wasn't something that
was gonna come and go
and and you know I'm sure someday there
won't be something better than email I
don't know if it's the new Google
Hangouts or what you know google tried
wave and all these different things but
that's been the thing that I focused on
except felt like it was more evergreen
it wasn't something that was gonna come
and go and die off and but I do think
that there's a lot to be said for social
media and we just we don't have a social
media person and we don't have enough
time to make it more interactive for now
can we understand you have roughly 93
thousand or so from your amazing
Kickstarter campaign for mannchild after
you know fees taxes and whatnot in the
bank yet you've been very transparent
and said that this is not currently
enough for you to make the first feature
film to the level that you want to make
it do you feel that maybe manchild is
too ambitious of a first feature well
it's certainly an ambitious first
feature you know I think the jury is out
and whether it's too ambitious
you know there are a couple of things
going on with the project other than you
know constantly working on and trying to
get it made
and I think one of the challenges is
that no matter even if you run a
filmmaking website as I do and you know
I won my first filmmaking award 12 years
ago so I've been you know pursuing this
for a while but you're always learning
things and they're always things you
didn't know when you started it and you
know as somebody who's done a lot of DIY
productions where not only was I doing a
lot of the craft elements as far as
being the DP and being the editor and
being the sound guy and being the
after-effects artist
thing the stuff that I've done has also
been logistical II very contained so you
know the Westside that wet my web series
yes were out on the streets we're
walking down the street with no permits
and we didn't have insurance and you
know we were literally breaking into
crack houses and climbing across roofs
and just you know there are things that
you hey you don't want to do repeatedly
for your own health and for the safety
of your actors and performers be they're
illegal and you know see you definitely
want to do these things with child
actors so I think you know I was
certainly a bit naive as far as how far
I thought I could stretch a dollar on a
real production where people are insured
and whether where you're paying for
locations and where you're doing things
you know not in a luxury way not with
trailers not with you know spending a
lot of money that doesn't need to be
spent which is the basics of having
permits and having insurance and making
sure that you know the child actors are
going to be protected or the adults if
someone gets hurt
you know we're filming a sports movie
and so once I was meeting with producers
there are course producers who are gonna
push this to be something that you don't
want to make it and that's a challenge
and I'm you know we're not looking to
make this into the blindside you know or
Rudy or some some of these larger sports
movies that you're you're used to
thinking of as a sports movie but there
are just it's an educational process to
look at a real budget and to say oh okay
you know we're all the ways that we can
trim money and then you get to a point
where the movie you wrote is gonna be
best served by minimum budget level and
that just wasn't you know as you said we
have 93 thousand in the bank and that's
even after we made this short you know
we haven't touched a penny of that and
there's nothing wrong with wanting
what's best for your movie and I could
go cut all of the basketball scenes from
the script and go make this movie but
they're all there for all those things
are there for a reason
and so for me you know regardless of
what the external understanding of what
I'm going through is at the end of the
day I exist to make this film the best
that could possibly be and you know I'm
gonna knock down walls and I'm gonna you
know take some comments of people you
know either misconstruing what I'm doing
or just feeling like I'm you know
abandoning the DIY ethos but ultimately
you know you want what's best for your
film and I think if you look at most
Kickstarter projects very few of those
their entire budget was raised through
Kickstarter and all my Kickstarter page
I say very clearly you can go back and
look at it because Kickstarter locks
your page after your campaign is over
and you can't change the word that I say
I'm looking for a producer and once I
meet with producers we're gonna do a
real budget and then we're gonna have
some hard decisions to make about
whether we cut things from the script or
need to raise more money or need to do
both so I think the jury is out on where
in between those different options we're
gonna end up but you know no one said
this is gonna be easy and at the end of
the day it takes me longer to make the
film that I wanted to but I make the
movie that I wanted to you know I'll
take that delay instead of sort of
trimming and cutting and turning this
into something that wasn't what I want
it to make in the first place what's the
current state of mannchild right now we
know that you made the beautiful short
film that we saw you know the state is
we are looking to well I'm working on a
new draft of the script as I always am
but you know it's not it does not idle
tweaking you know I basically spent four
months of my life making this short and
of course during the production of that
you go back and you read your script and
you see some changes you could
based on the experience of having made
this short so working on a new draft
always taking meetings and talking to
people about you know where we can shoot
and you know who the cast might be and
the crew and just the logistics of the
scheduling it's a it's a logistically
very complicated film as far as you know
most school movies star high schoolers
which means that you just go cast a
bunch of 18 19 20 year-olds and they're
all adults and so they can work long
hours and they're not in school
when you have a 13 year old lead it's
very unlikely you're gonna find an 18
year old that looks 13 maybe we will but
all sudden then your days are very short
and you can't be doing it at the same
time as the school year or if you do you
need to go hire a tutor full-time so
that they can you know it's that yeah
yeah your star can be getting an
education at the same time as making a
movie so you know as far as the school
year is concerned as far as the number
of days that you need to shoot because
your because your actual shooting time
is very short it creates a lot of
logistical challenges that make this a
very challenging first feature but you
know I think and I hope that I proved
with the short that all of those
challenges are what make this project
worth doing and those are the reasons
that this project hasn't been made
before there's part of the reason that
it hasn't been made before is because
it's not easy so you know we're still
taking these meetings and figuring out
when we're gonna shoot and everything
and things are moving forward it's just
always you know you don't know exactly
how they're going to move forward until
you're on the precipice of of actually
shooting you could put in a capsule what
enabled you to raise a hundred and
twenty five thousand dollars on
Kickstarter what would be the most
important factors audience building you
know I never would have launched a
campaign for six figures if I hadn't
spent two years building on
audience with a website so you know it's
one of those ten years to an overnight
success kind of thing where all the work
you've put in in the back you hope you
know helps you do this thing that was
the most ambitious thing I've ever done
in my life as far as you know a
Kickstarter campaign is all or nothing
and when you hit launch and it says
$115,000 and it says zero dollars and
zero cents you know from here to there
is a long way to go but I felt like I
had done everything in my power over the
last couple of years to to build a
website and I felt like enough people
knew who I was and that it was a strong
enough project with some external
validation from from IFP and from
Lincoln Center that it was you know I I
felt like if I failed that I would have
done everything I possibly could and
then I wouldn't feel bad about it so you
know the main thing was was building an
audience and the way that I went about
it is different than a lot of people
will as far as you know I was talking
about the craft of filmmaking in the
behind the scenes stuff as opposed to
just this one particular project but
ultimately I think it comes down to that
approach of saying you know Kickstarter
IndieGoGo these things aren't magic you
know you you you can make a great video
and but ultimately you have to have a
feeling of you've been working on this
for a long time and that people know who
you are and have are invested in your
success so it's not you know I think the
kicks the Kickstarter campaigns that
don't succeed a lot of the times are
ones where people you know saw somebody
else doing this and thought oh well I
can do that too and they didn't really
understand the amount of work that the
other people did successful campaigns
did it not only during their campaign
but before it went a lot of that work
happens let's pretend you were gonna run
a second crowdfunding campaign what
would you do the same and what would you
do differently this time
that that task seems so daunting I would
have a team you know I ran in my
campaign 100% myself I didn't have
interns or anybody sending emails on my
behalf or anybody doing you know help me
with me with the video production you
know I wanted to I could have probably
but it was just one of those things
where you know you get efficient at
working at the speed of thought and
doing things yourself and executing them
that I am that was doing it myself but
were I to do another Kickstarter
campaign that would definitely not be
the case because you know obviously
there's a lot of things that you need to
be doing during the campaign or there's
a lot of things that you could have done
had you had more hands on deck
so I think having a team is really
valuable and that was one of the
challenges of my project was that it was
just a script so I didn't have a
producer attached I didn't have actors I
didn't have other people who were you
know invested in the success of this
project who could help not only be on
screen in the video but also just with
the tweeting and the facebooking and the
spreading the word and reaching out to
contacts so that would be the main thing
is you know just having a team in place
that would have been nice for someone
that doesn't have a team let's suppose
maybe they've built an audience maybe
they've been really diligent with their
social media and again not to bash
social media I know I said before that
sometimes it seems like a giant time
waste but it is valuable and you do meet
great people all across the world so
what would you what would you say aside
from that what are some of the other
things I mean you had an amazing pitch
video and I think that's something a lot
of people miss they just put up a
trailer and they don't they don't
include themselves and so people saw
that okay well I want to invest in this
guy even if I don't know mm-hmm you know
I think for me if it was something where
I was trying to check every box to get
myself the best chance of succeeding
with the campaign and one of those was
you know making a video that was
entertaining and spoke to other
creatives but not
actually having a trailer and not having
had anything shot that was a very
particular challenge and I think that as
the campaign was coming together if I
didn't feel like the video was turning
out okay that you know would have set a
lower goal I didn't have an audience
that I could reach via email email tens
of thousands of people you know right
when the campaign launched I would have
said a lower bowl so it was kind of like
all those things together is what you
know I think made the campaign a success
so that it would you know not everybody
who backed my campaign came from my
website you know and I think
front-loading the work and planning it
out is really where the campaign is made
or broken for a lot for a lot of time
for a lot of people as far as you know
doing the work on the video and planning
it out you know making sure that you're
running the campaign during a time where
there is no national holiday at a
particular point where you're gonna be
trying to raise money and everyone's
gone or you know if you're going on
vacation yourself in the middle that's
not a great idea you know just sort of
having that those strategies and
front-loading the work is really a great
way to you know just to put yourself in
the best position can you talk about
filmmakers work ethic I know you've
mentioned before I think it was on our
radio show that you would actually clock
your work like a time clock almost like
an attorney does working on a certain
client yeah you know filmmaking
especially independent filmmaking is so
challenging because I think a lot of
jobs if you're good at them if you work
really hard and if you're smart about
the work you do you can make a living
doing them or you can make a lot of
money doing them and sometimes it's
filmmaking and you can do all those
things and not be making any money so to
me you know I knew that I felt like I
had to be working really hard at this in
addition to having a strategy and having
ability and you know that the work
itself is not gonna get done unless you
spend the time doing it and I'm big on
analytics and sort of you know numbers
cutting through your subjective
impression of yourself and especially as
somebody who runs a website I got I need
to know how much time I'm spending
running that website versus how much
time I'm spending working in my
screenplay and to not let you know the
everyday tasks that you need to do like
answering email and the you know dozen
different things I do for no film school
to push aside the the other work that
you're doing so that's why I track hours
so that I can be honest with myself
about you know if I think well last
month I worked really hard on this thing
I can go look at it and say oh no you
didn't you know or I can say I'm you
know I'm co-writing another screenplay
am i letting that overtake this project
or you know if I am consulting or
working with somebody else you know how
much time am i spending on that and how
much is that taking away from you know
manchild in my project so I think that's
our most limited resources time and
therefore that's the most valuable thing
to track it seems that we all have this
level this to varying degrees of adult
ad D with Twitter and Facebook and
everybody checking different things and
even when you check email now there's
incoming news headlines and things like
that so how do you minimize distractions
for yourself what are some of the tips
and what are your biggest distractions
you know I think we all struggle with
this especially now with email and you
know feeling like we should be on social
media and available when I'm doing my
best at it is when I'm batching these
things so I'll go carve out a four hour
chunk to work on a screenplay where you
know you can use an application like
math is something called freedom where
you shut off your internet it won't let
you on the internet unless you you know
restart your computer and then you know
you feel terrible about yourself because
you couldn't stay off the internet for
four hours we're kind of you know what
kind of screenwriter are you so I think
you know when you if you're able to step
back from it and think about do I really
need to be on my email
you know once every half hour or more
the answer is no you know so I think
sort of managing your time in that sense
and carving out large chunks of time
where you're not available is the the
key thing to being productive I think
but you know I struggled with it in the
same way that everybody else does and
you know when you're when you're going
and checking your email for the third
time in ten minutes it's just I can be
really hard so I think sometimes having
those tools and that separation you know
what did that be physically getting up
and going somewhere else and making sure
you don't get distracted all those
approaches can help but it's definitely
a challenge that I think all of us face
so forgive me who I thought you had
mentioned before that you did some
couchsurfing or that when you were first
you know working on the website you
stayed at a friend's house or you did
something yeah no I actually you know
I've worked at MTV for three years and I
got laid off with 700 other MTV
employees in the same day and after that
I went and I had a project called third
rail which is a murder mystery on a New
York City subway train that is sort of
interactive in transmedia and you know
we had an agent and we went out to LA
and we pitched that I spent a lot of
time taking meetings and making script
revisions and you what amounted to a lot
of free work you know because people are
always set up at one place and they want
you to make these changes and all sudden
you're realizing that your job is to be
on conference calls and to be taking
meetings not actually making movies so
my experience coming back to New York
from that was I felt like the projects
that I want to make are risky and I felt
like the people I was meeting with in
Hollywood their job
to mitigate risk you know if they take
risks and they failed and they lose
their job so I wanted to come back and
have something that I owned that I could
hopefully turn into some sort of regular
income stream that would allow me to
make risky projects without having to
say yes to something that I wasn't
interested in doing you know some of our
pitches were oh well you know we this
doesn't really fit into our wheelhouse
this is an arm mandate but if you if you
want to do something with this you know
kind of quick property that we own you
know pitch us something based on that
that's not what I wanted to do so that's
when I came back and I wanted to start
no film school but you know having been
laid off from my job I didn't have any
income and I knew that starting a
website from scratch was gonna take if
it ever took off would take a long time
so the biggest the best thing I could do
was cut out all then my need to pay rent
you know get my bills down as low as
they could possibly be and so thankfully
I had some friends I could stay with you
know so I was I was in several states I
was in Costa Rica for a while which was
great cheaper than New York and their
beaches are amazing and you know the
cost of living in New York is so high
that essentially I just moved out of my
apartment and then I lived live
different places where any place they
had internet access I could be launching
the website I could be blogging I could
be putting up new posts and researching
what to do so that was great and I think
so much of pursuing a creative career is
taking risks and the risk versus reward
of leaving your day job is a really hard
thing for a lot of people to do and
whenever I get a chance I always
encourage people you know what
especially you know if you're at a time
where you don't have you know kids
depending on you if you're at a time
where the risk of losing your regular
income stream is great it's probably
gonna get greater the older you get so
if you believe in yourself and you want
to pursue this artistic pursuit then
there's probably no time like
present and I think a lot of times it's
hard because you don't know what its
gonna look like
or what you're gonna do but there's no
really way to find that out until you
give yourself some space from you know
eight hours a day of doing somebody
else's bidding and so for me it was I
have to do this
I always said at MTV that I was gonna be
my last day job and so it was me
sticking to my word and you know putting
my money where my mouth is or putting my
lack of money where I don't know that I
don't know it gets mixed up but uh you
know I think I had to do it and
thankfully it worked out but you know I
imagine what would have happened if I
just did the safe thing and I just took
another day job and I was a senior
designer at MTV you can make great money
doing you know design make better money
doing that then you know filmmaking for
the most part but so I think I think
taking that risk was the best thing I
could have done and you have to make
sacrifices to do that and for me it was
well I'm not gonna have an address for a
year but it was absolutely it was you
know it was it was great what advice can
you give to someone else maybe they're
not even a filmmaker but they're quote
sleeping on someone's couch I've been
there and there's a feeling of sort of
powerlessness and you're like am I ever
gonna come out of this so what are some
of the tips you can give to other people
that I'm sure you had some pretty dark
nights to the soul or maybe you didn't
and it gets scary and but then you came
out and now things were better so how
did you do that how did you kind of keep
those commitments to yourself because
there are probably days when you could
get lost and say you know what I'm gonna
find the safe route again you know I
think for for filmmaking and for
creative pursuits the one of the biggest
challenges is when you need permission
and so the whole idea for me getting
away from from from pitching things in
LA during that stretch was you know and
that's how I watched my career was just
making a webseries and putting up online
and not requiring somebody else's
permission or approval and I think when
it comes down to is just doing the work
you know we can be here talking about it
and you can do consultancies and
you can write blog posts but ultimately
you know that's the only reason I track
hours is to make sure that you're doing
the work at the end of the day and you
know the more things you can do that
don't require someone else you know the
better as far as getting your foot in
the door making something putting it out
there and you know hopefully getting
attention for it and moving on to the
next step so you know we're all gonna
run into writer's block we're all gonna
have those dark nights where you know is
what I'm doing is a terrible and never
gonna make it at this but but for me the
the work ethic and just sitting down
there and focusing on the work is what
keeps me sort of keeps me on track
because I you know I believe in I
believe in failing forward so you're
gonna learn as much from something that
failed if not more than you are from
something that was successful so
therefore the only real formula is to
just keep doing the work sounds like you
weren't doing too much ruminating you
were just you were just doing it like
not a lot of oh is this it sounds like
you were just I mean you know we're all
introspective rumination can be great as
an artist but my big thing is just no
complaining you know no whining no
complaining
we all are struggling with you know
massive obstacles and complaining gets
you nowhere so do you feel you made a
mistake
skipping Film Festival's just to go
directly to the audience with amateur I
mean it's been what two months I guess
as soon as you've posted the short
online do you wish you'd gone the film
festival route or was this your whole
plan to just post it online yeah that's
something that I will wonder about and
yeah that's one of the challenges of
filmmaking is that one movie comes out
and you think it's really good and no
one wins no one would to see it I mean
while some you know a lot of people are
going to see something else and you
don't know whether it's the strategy of
it why that is you know here's one of
the harder things about filmmaking is
that the success of your your project is
predicated on so many different things
and there's no real way to go
back and change it so you know to me the
releasing a short online for free the
success of that is predicated on half
moon how do we reach the sports world
and the film launch couldn't have gone
better you know on day one we're on the
front page of indieWIRE filemaker
magazine short of the week directors
notes
it's a Vimeo staff pick you know I think
that the strategy of releasing it for
free online instead of going to
festivals was sound but that does open
you up to the vagaries of the news cycle
and so the day I released that the day I
premiered it was when the Boston
Marathon bombings happened and that's a
that's not only a huge news story as it
should be but it's also a sports related
story so any website that I was reaching
out to that I had initial contact with
suddenly they had you know many many
many stories to do for weeks about this
in the fall you know the following week
Jason Collins became the first NBA
player to come out of the closet another
huge news story as it should be
meanwhile the NBA playoffs are going on
at the same time so I think you know I
have a lot of experience with strategy
and planning and all these things and I
think my strategy was sound but no
matter what your strategy is things will
always happen that make it you know
there are a lot of moving parts and so I
was trying to get out in front of the
NBA Playoffs but that window closed when
the Boston Marathon bombings happened
and I can't complain about that because
obviously a lot of people have really
really terrible things that happened as
a result of that but in your over in
this little film making world and you're
like I can't complain but just you know
this thing really made my release my
little film release more challenging so
you know I don't don't necessarily know
that it's online release only vs. Film
Festival's the short is still going to
be playing at some film festivals
despite the fact that it's online and I
think you know I think there are a lot
of talking points there as far as some
festivals have a policy that they will
play stuff that played
and some have a policy that they won't
but there's a lot of gray area as far as
you know what's your exposure been
online do you need to take it down
during the time it's playing the
festival you know are you playing out a
competition because you are online a lot
of things that I think for me it's worth
it just to explore those those issues
from my perspective firsthand based on
experience and I'll be sharing that what
I find on no film school but you know
the jury is still out as far as the
strategy of releasing a short who we've
been able to reach you know we're gonna
be releasing it on YouTube with sort of
a different strategy as kind of a second
wave and you know I'm still talking to a
number of websites that I hope it will
end up on and you know ultimately my
approach was making the short in general
as opposed to releasing it online was
that it's gonna be a great thing for the
feature regardless of how it turns out
who sees it because for me it's a proof
of concept and it's getting on the set
and working at a certain pace and
finding good crew members and just you
know the on set reps of making a movie
in this genre but I think there are a
lot of different approaches you could
take with a short you know one would be
okay you make it you hold it back if
you're trying to raise fun right fund
raising you approach investors privately
with a screening it's good they feel
special that they're invested in making
this happen because they feel if they've
had special access that would be one way
of doing it you know the other is to
submit the film festivals and wait and
hopefully you know you play a
prestigious festival maybe you even win
some award and that kind of validation
allows you to then go pitch to investors
and while it's still not online I think
I'll always wonder about these different
approaches but there's really no way of
knowing beforehand oh this is right or
this is wrong this will work this won't
and for me ever since I got started I've
always felt that you know there's a
place for drama and for quality content
line and that's always been a goal of
mine so it just made sense to go with
this approach especially as we've been
in pre-production on man childhood and
development for so long that waiting for
a festival or doing these things behind
closed doors it was only gonna you know
make the delay longer so I you know I
wanted to rush I wanted to put it out
there and have people see it you know
it's a work I'm extremely proud of and
so that was ultimately kind of the the
decision maker as far as you know
putting it online it's a short prequel
so you want people to watch it and feel
like they want to see more and in that
sense the more people that see it the
better in terms of dealing with your
plan of action and then the world acts
of God whatever things coming in and
taking over and we've heard so many
people say well I've launched a crowd
put funding campaign but then this came
this crowdfunding campaign or this world
event happened it sounds like your plan
is just to keep going not complain and
just proceed as normal or are there
times that maybe people should pull back
and say you know what this is probably
the wrong time
to do this you know I think when you're
when you're sort of spread thin and
you're overworked and you're just
pushing forward yourself there is no
really pulling back you know I would
love to have a number of consultants and
we have a meeting and everyone
strategizes and we break and we come
back a week from now and then we plan
this other thing but you know it's me
it's me pushing the rock up the hill and
so I feel like any time I you know like
over the rock it's just rolling back
down so for me yeah just the momentum of
it and keep pushing and have the
attitude that this is gonna happen with
or without whoever's involvement you
know whoever you're meeting with next
you're making it and hopefully they want
to be on board and if not you're making
it anyway that's kind of the approach I
have and you know I guess there'll be
plenty of time in the future to take
meetings and pause and strategize and
you know take our time with it but but
you know I'm not not letting go that
that rock at this point let's talk about
amateur what you shot it on how you
secure the look
Haitians yeah so amateur you know is the
short prequel for manchild and I came
about because I felt that making it
short was the last box I could check as
far as you know okay I'm gonna write the
script is a script good does it get
recognition from you know places like
IFP and I considered as a gonna grant
from Tribeca okay those boxes are
checked it's been externally validated
okay what's next
well can I run a crowdfunding campaign
that's big enough that shows people hey
there's interest in this movie and then
I have an audience that would end up you
know result in me bringing you know six
figures of financing to the table with
myself in addition to the script okay
that box is checked what else can I do
okay let's see if I can make a short
that's a proof of concept that's the
same genre that shows I can direct
basketball and I understand the sport
that shows I can direct young
african-american actors because the
entire movie you know they keep the star
of the movie is in every single scene
it's not going to be a movie where
there's a bunch of adults talking and
that's the majority of the film so the
short came about because I wanted to do
something that was of the same genre and
actually has some of the same characters
as the feature as a proof of concept and
when I initially had the idea for it it
was starting out very small I was I was
thinking about shooting it myself and
most of it was gonna take place and you
know school hallways which I figured
would be easier to secure than an actual
gymnasium and at the time I was being
with my producer chip horahan who
produced frozen river and any day now
and we were talking about the feature
and I sent him over at the the short
script and he liked it a lot and all of
sudden you know now the team is to
Austin were I'm scouting gyms and New
York City he's scouting gyms in New
Jersey it's coming together I went
my DP Greg Wilson who he and I again had
had a number of conversations about the
future he'd read the script and I sent
him the script for the short and said
hey I'm trying to make this you know
soon really soon and then our team was
three so Austin we had multiple people
calling in favors and it was becoming
larger than what I had originally
imagined but in a good way because I
wrote it to be something that was very
achievable knowing all the challenges
that the feature is facing I essentially
started with what can I write that is
basically a conversation between two
people in one location and can I make it
dramatic and can I make it rewarding and
all that it's gonna be dependent on you
know the writing and the directing and
the performances and the story all of
which are the most important things in
filmmaking so there was that sort of
challenge that I set out for myself
thankfully chip and Greg were also you
know pushing the ball up the hill and we
were able to call in just a lot of
favors because one of the one of the
great things about doing a weekend shoot
is someone you know might be available
that weekend they're not working
otherwise so you can go get equipment or
personnel for less than it would have
been you know that's one of the
challenges when you're shooting a movie
for 20 or 30 days you can't call it a
favorite for 20 or 30 days so you know
originally we were gonna shoot it on my
red scarlet and Greg my DP hadn't shot
on red before so it was a good
opportunity for him I mean not that he
hasn't shot at things that high-end I
mean he should be on Alexa's and things
but but getting the red experience was
gonna be good either way but then when
the weekend rolled around because we've
been already talking to rental houses
through all of our connections other
equipment became available through
friends from the rental house we didn't
know what lenses we would be shooting on
until the day before when they said hey
we have these areas UN's available and
we said okay great we're shooting on
that now so we ended up not even
touching my red scarlet because Greg's
friend
it's an epoch that was available so also
we were shooting on that and I think for
an online release you probably can't
tell the difference between 4k and 5k
and but of course it was just well we
have a better camera we'll use that it's
not costing us anything like it
literally would have been more expensive
for us to go buy a t4i DSLR and bring it
to set and shoot on that because we were
able to get you know equipment based on
a favor so you know the idea was that I
didn't want to make excuses for this
short other than the challenges of the
locations and the fact that it's you
know not necessarily an action-packed
like viral online video with music and
special effects and everything I mean I
think there are challenges of releasing
online in that sense but I didn't want
to have to make excuses for the
production quality the sound quality you
know the gym like these are all things
that are as a trio we were able to
secure into scout and you know once you
have a good DP you know Greg has
connections to crew members and you know
we pay people but we would not we didn't
pay people what you know that they would
have been paid if this was a mayonnaise
commercial so we were able to bring it
in and you know I think the production
quality is really high you know we had
one sound guy not - and he was able to
do the booming and the mixing and
everything himself and so really we were
able to pull it together
I don't really proud of it and so
hopefully you know that proof of concept
is gonna be checking that last box that
I that I spoke up and saying oh okay now
I get the vision for the feature and now
I get the level of you know performance
and storytelling that that you know
makes you want to see the feature and
you know we'll see what what comes
henceforth from releasing this so you
had 48 hours was that right to do the
entire film or just use the gym oh we
didn't have 48 hours to use the gym we
actually we wrapped the gym in a single
day and the challenge was so chip my
producer found this great locations
Edison New Jersey and we went and we
scouted it and we said this is great the
challenge was that a kids soccer game
had the gym reserved in the middle of
the day so you know it was a weekend
shoot a day and then at night you can't
really do a night and a day because the
crews gonna there's be no turnaround
time so we had to shoot the gym on
Saturday and the exterior night on
Sunday so couldn't you know avoid this
kids soccer game so yeah we had one day
in the gym and in the middle we had to
move all our equipment the kids come in
and play their soccer game and then
continue shooting which meant that we
ended up shooting a number of things out
of order which meant that you know we
had less time in the gym but we were
able to schedule our lunch when they
were in the gym and then go shoot our
locker room scene and then come back but
literally we were picking up you know
there's a couple edits where someone's
having a conversation and it's a
two-shot and then the close up they are
cut into was you know four hours later
after these kids have played a soccer
game and we're trying to match our
lighting and there are a lot of
logistical challenges to the short that
I that I hope don't show up when you
watch it especially given the fact that
you know this short opens with some
action and it always takes time to film
to get it right and to have the action
match and and you know to single camera
shoot so we're recovering things from
multiple angles so most of that short of
that nine-minute short 75% of that is
shot after lunch on day one in the gym
so you know it's not a luxurious
situation to be saying oh you know okay
take 16 we're going no it's very few
takes it is moving very quickly it's
everyone's sort of you know making
sacrifices as far as what you can do
with lighting how many takes you can get
you know you can just changing the
staging because the lights are a certain
way you can get to the scene faster if
you don't you know move over there so I
think it you know it was a really good
set of challenges to face to be able to
prove myself in that environment and
I'm proud of what we ended up with
regardless of all those challenges but
especially because you know when you
know what you went through as a
filmmaker the audience is never gonna
know that so you sort of just have to be
internally proud about what you were
able to achieve given the limited
circumstances you've had how many people
then were on the crew was it five uh
yeah we had we had a sizable crew it was
definitely the largest group I'd ever
worked with because the crew was greater
than myself you know I'm used to our web
series that we did exactly Berman my
co-director he and I were the crew so we
were the sound you know camera
everything this was actually the first
time that I'd stepped onto a set and my
name was on the slate yeah oh action oh
this is great
you know I'm not I'm not pulling focus I
can actually give the actor a note and
not you know be distracted by the fact
that I blew a focus pull myself at the
same time so you know I think we had
there were about 12 people on set
including including you know cast so but
you know we were able to get a lot out
of our crew you know and someone that
was some of that was some you know
people who came on last-minute for free
and but yeah that was definitely it was
good to be able to have access to the
lighting setup that we had and be able
to have you know a great di T Tom Wong
on set there's been a lot of red stuff
and just you know working with
professionals is you know there's no
substitute for it so it was great you
know being able to give us as much as we
did in a short amount of time because
everybody was proficient at their job
and everyone was on the same page he
tell us about the car that was in that
right so there's a there's a car in too
short and if you haven't seen the short
go to manchild film back home and watch
it so we don't you know spoiler alert
so yeah you know we needed this car and
needed to be a nice car in the short and
it's actually a zip car so you know if
you go around a car from a rental house
you're gonna show up and they're going
to give you
for Carlene what you signed up for you
know it's impossible to know the color
of the vehicle you're getting so I
didn't realize that Zipcar had luxury
vehicles but they do and so the funny
thing was we were actually gonna shoot
the exterior scene on day one so I went
and I ran in a zip car and it was
Mercedes and I show up to set on the
first day in a Mercedes and I'm like
great this is a low-budget scrappy short
and the directors like you know we can't
pay you but in an unplayable Mercedes so
we didn't get that shot the first day
because you know as I said we wrapped
the whole gym in a day so we're going to
day two and which was fine because we
were shooting day two in anyway but it
just meant I needed to rent the car
again and so on day two I get a call
from Zipcar and for those who don't have
that car in their cities if cars are the
place where you can rent a vehicle by
the hour as opposed to by the day and
you remember and the gas and insurance
is included the thing I was worried
about was that there gonna be a big zip
car sticker on the back and that would
kind of ruin it but thankfully their
luxury vehicles at least right now don't
have branding on it so day two I got a
call from Zipcar saying we're sorry sir
but the zip car you have reserved was
just in an accident and is no longer
available so it's classic Murphy's Law
indie-film stuff like you try and
imagine everything they can go wrong but
I didn't imagine that my car smashed up
by the side of the road right now the
one that I had reserved so I said to
them well this is a strange request but
I need you to find me that same vehicle
for all day you know or at least the
vehicle closed like close to it and you
know I've rented the silver ones that I
would show up at night and the lights
better as opposed to a black or dark
blue or something so you know even even
just having the vehicle wasn't chat was
the challenge but then of course on day
two Here I am showing up on set in a
different luxury vehicle than I did in
day one so I show up in a Mercedes on
day one and then I'm day two I show up
in the BMW and it's like yeah you know
indie-film that's that's that's how we
do things over here we don't spend the
money on the personnel we split all our
transport to the set apparently so in
addition in addition to you know the zip
car being a certain challenge the other
challenge we faced was we you know we
did a casting call when we read our
actors but for the the mother and father
were just
based on a head shot at a real and the
actors that we originally had playing
the mother and father and who are
described in the sides as driving a car
this is a problem you'll only face in
New York neither of them had a driver's
license and neither of them had ever
driven a car and so when they showed up
we said wait a second you're showing up
to play the role of driver and you've
never driven the vehicle and that wasn't
something that you thought you might
want to let us know so not only did we
have a car beat you know and a vehicle
get taken out of commission because it
was in an accident but we also had
drivers who couldn't drive so you know
during on day two was was a necessity
for numerous reasons was it just a
stationary did they did drive off right
yeah do they drive up and drive haha
yeah so at one point we're talking I'm
talking about producer you know can you
drive up that you know as a white guy
like wearing gloves or something and
then we'll cut to the close-up and we'll
swap in the actor playing the
african-american driver and then we'll
cut back to the wide and you'll drive
the car off and I'm thinking about like
oh gosh you know am I going to be an
after effects like trying to switch
somebody in like it you know all all the
sort of things that go wrong there but
thankfully we ended up just bringing in
an actor who can actually drive a car
and that was the best solution so what
were the things that you were
pre-planning for you've always talked
about you know when you said that with
your Kickstarter campaign you
front-loaded all the work so what did
you front-load in terms of this short
film you know the casting was the big
thing I cast a great actor Lyle Pina as
the recruiter and he I knew him because
he was the the town boss in my web
series from several years ago and you
know Lyle is a trooper he's been in a
number of movies and I felt that having
him on board from day one would really
help us as far as you know being able to
do a casting call and being able to read
the two of our two leads together to see
what kind of chemistry they had as
opposed to
you know with a casting director with
myself so that was kind of the big thing
you know I knew this is going to be a
film that was made or broken in the
performances especially with Curtis cook
junior as the basketball player it's a
very nuanced role that you have to be
able to play you have to be able to be
believable as a basketball player both
from physicality of playing the sport
but also from your attitude and the way
you carry yourself you have to show that
you're a highly competitive athlete but
your performance also has to have a
certain vulnerability again go see the
short if you haven't seen it
spoiler alert but you know he he's he's
um you know he's sandbagging he's you
know he's playing he's playing dad he's
playing possum a little bit and so you
have to be able to show owner ability as
well so that to me was the big thing was
was finding the right actor and you know
Curtis showed up was the only actor II
read that didn't have a headshot and
just just nailed it and the rest of the
day we you know it was it was who can be
who can be Curtis and then I did a
callback so I think a lot of the
front-loading the preparation you don't
want to get on set and find out and you
know find an unpleasant surprise so to
me this is a basketball movie that needs
to have convincing basketball one of the
problems that you're faced with when
you're making is say Hollywood sports
film was that this actor Lee wants to be
in it but maybe that actor can actually
who so then you're you have a guy who
just can't really dribble and has a
broken looking a jump shot you know
you're cutting through the room and the
ball comes in this is expressly not that
film you know this is a movie that I
think has to appeal both to indie film
fans and real basketball fans as a fan
and player myself so the casting call
the callbacks are scheduled to be two
days later in a casting room and I just
I couldn't have that so on Monday for
our Tuesday callbacks
I'm calling gyms in Manhattan I said I
need to reserve an hour in your gym day
before you know less than 24 hours
notice and I managed to find place so we
did a callbacks there so not
do we reread you know full scenes and
really sort of have our best actors come
back but I also was able to set the
actors and play one-on-one against each
other and see what they could and
couldn't do and see who really could
handle the ball and who could shoot and
find out you know what they what they
can and can't do in the sense that then
I can could direct towards their
strengths on the court and not be
wasting time on set finding out that oh
I've written a scene I've written
something for you to do that you're not
very good at but you're really
convincing this other thing so we're
gonna waste a bunch of time shooting
this one thing and then making an
adjustment to go to this other thing so
that way I could walk on set already
having a choreographed in my head and
you know I'm a webseries the west side
there's a lot of action there's
gunfights there's a lot of after-effects
there's always special effects in there
and we didn't do a single storyboard I
feel very comfortable knowing screen
direction I've been editing for 12 years
you know I think we're doing visual
effects or something I would definitely
want a storyboard for those purposes but
I feel very comfortable walking into a
set knowing where to put the camera and
how to get continuous action so it was
more the front loading of the
performance and the ability to play the
sport and knowing what was going to
happen on the screen more so than it was
the front loading of storyboarding and
previz or anything like that I did a
shot list and that was my main planning
and then on set I ended up having to
kill a lot of the shots of course to
make the day given that we were doing
you know seven and a half pages in a day
or something including you know plus
plus basketball action so I think the
front-loading is really just making sure
that you know trying to minimize the
number of unpleasant surprises that
you're gonna face on the day where did
you post the casting notice for amateur
so we actually had a casting director
matthew wolf and a casting associate
Celia Celia how on this short I'm used
to doing casting myself and posting it
on you know backstage actors access and
but you know one of the things when we
were trying to get this short made
quickly and I think as soon as you're
you know trying to compress the timeline
the best thing you can do is let other
people do their job so mm-hmm that's a
question for them
I did have some friends on Facebook say
hey I just saw a posting that for
something that you're directing on my
after speed but I didn't you know
honestly I didn't know where that was
you know my job was just as director to
show up and and you know not to see who
could nail a role but then how they take
direction and take him off with a few
different directions and from there the
from there it was a matter of rehearsal
you know I think the nice thing about
casting is short is that someone can go
read the entire piece and know the arc
and know what's coming so that they come
in and I just reading a scene context
free so you really you know with a 9
page script you really get a sense of
who grasped the character but you know
do they understand the complexities and
can they make the turn at the end so
that was nice to be able to you know
have that and had actors come in and
just completely get the performance and
get the character you know felt great as
the screenwriter and then as a director
we did a rehearsal at my apartment the
day before the shoot which was really
was really what allowed us to you know
on the day be making small tweaks as
opposed to having do it global redo and
say okay you know this scene is way too
blank and we need to get on target
during you know while you're burning
through money on the set so you know the
short being very there's you know very
definite arcs in each character there's
a very definite power dynamic that is
shifting and to be able to rehearse and
sort of say okay you know what your
level of confidence is at this point and
how you know knowing where it's going
and to sort of break down each
individual scene and have that tone
already I have all must be on the same
page already going into the day is
really what allowed us to you know
achieve what we achieve given the page
count the number of steps we were doing
you know you know and what is
essentially except for the last scene in
one day shoot so your strategy with
amateur transitioning into man-child a
feature mm-hmm what's on deck what do
you have planned right you know the the
strategy of releasing amateur
for young line is really about other
than it being a long time since I've
released a film that I directed and just
you know sort of having that that that
feeling of my god good this thing is out
there and you know I feel like that is
worth a lot right there but but really
the strategy is reaching the sports
world and the basketball world you know
this is a story that I think hasn't been
told before I'm talking about the
feature and I think there's a lot of
interest in that as far as you know
there's an ongoing suit against the NCAA
from something acara about our shouldn't
college athletes be paid you know I hate
a lot people don't know how young the
recruiting has gotten I think a lot of
basketball players have gone through
this themselves a lot of hooks in the
basketball world so the reason that I
released it free online was to reach
that world and we're gonna be we're
gonna be releasing on YouTube and making
sort of a second a second launch for the
short to that end and I would just say
that you know for anybody who's anybody
who's watching this if you have you know
sports or basketball connections you
know I think those are the people that
I'm really trying to get in front of so
email me at Ryan at manchild film calm
and you know I think really what you
know just sort of talk about what we're
doing know film school that's the site
exists for everybody to be helping each
other and I think the site is gonna be
more of that going forward as we
redesign and you know it's amazing
putting this out there and hearing from
other filmmakers in the community people
saying hey I know this guy there get in
touch with him like I've met great
people that way and you know the lesson
has been that cold emails basically just
go to nowhere and I get cold emails all
the time you know the offshoot of that
is that I know how to write them at
least you know I'm not writing
ten paragraphs and trying to make things
very easy on people when I'm still not
hearing back so that's kind of the
challenge but the great thing about the
filmmaking community is that oh this guy
who is that guy and they pass it on and
people really like your short and then
things are in motion because of that so
you know releasing amateur online has
been just another example of sort of the
community and the networking making
something possible and hopefully you
know at the at the end of the day that's
gonna be what makes this this feature
get made
not just the the crowdfunding and the
Kickstarter and the new film school
audience but also just filmmakers
talking to each other and helping each
other out is really that's really what
my side is all about and hopefully you
know at the end of the day and an shot
would be a good example of that too